well there were many challenges but I
would say the most the biggest challenge
was how to make this game
easy and fun to play I mean at the
beginning we had bunch of computer
algorithms and theories that we could
use but not but none of those were all
of those workers for the expose and none
of us were well easily understandable by
in that by novices and our job was to
pick a subset of a subset of theories
that people might have to know and try
to try to make my hour come home with
easy an ax analogy and created levels
level levels of tutorials that people
can easily go through and just start
understanding the game how the game
works how the game works and eventually
how the RNA folding works in theories
and from our bed and from our beta beta
testing from our formal experience
experiences from beta testing I think we
did a pretty good job on that the only
one almost no one no one in Arkham you
know beta testing community had
experience in studying all day but they
are doing really well and actually most
of them are actually solving problems
faster than we are actually posting
problems and even actually solving the
forms that one of the one of the best
computer algorithms could not solve
there are many aspects to making the
game fun the first of aspect was
thoughts who make the video very trifle
underwater and this cute little paw
these cute little faces that's wiggling
around and many special effects as you
play through the game and moreover we
made we made constant really added in a
concept of competitions so you get to
you get to play compete with each other
you aren't points by clearing possible
and you want to earn more points by then
clearing more purpose than other people
you want to do better than other people
and that's actually a core aspect to
making the making the game fun yes I
find myself in the gaming in fact yes
when I want me when I need a break from
the break from developing the game I
just start playing the game although
unfortunately I find a lot of lot of our
players to better than me so